Sie sind auf der Jagd und
sie werden immer mehr:
Schatzräuber.
Archäologen schlagen Alarm.
Marion Brüggler ist Ausgrabungsleiterin
auf einem römischen Gräberfeld,
2000 Jahre alt.
Aus Angst vor illegalen Sondengängern
graben sie und ihr Team,
wenn möglich,
nur noch unter Geheimhaltung.
Wenn dann mit denen so eine Art
Fundfieber durchgeht
und die dann einfach immer
weiter runtergraben,
ist möglichweise das Herzstück eines …,
das datierend ist oder sonst eine
Aussage erlaubt, ist dann weg.
Und damit für die Wissenschaftler
für immer verloren.
Der Schaden durch illegale Sondengänger
ist schwer zu beziffern,
dürfte aber laut Polizei
in die Millionen gehen.
Die Schatzsuche mit speziellen Sonden
ist zum Volkssport geworden.
Viele suchen hier in Camouflage
mit bestem technischen Gerät das
große Abenteuer und den größten Fund.
Man geht ja mit ’ner gewissen Vorstellung
in dieses Hobby hinein.
Und dann hat man irgendwann mal
dieses Signal auf einem Gebiet,
vielleicht was wirklich auch Interessantes
und man glaubt: Das ist es eben.
Jedes Jahr veranstaltet die
Szene Schatzsuchermeisterschaften.
In einer großen Rallye werden Metall-
und Goldmünzen vergraben.
Wer die meisten und teuersten findet,
wird Deutscher Meister.
Gold!!! Gold! Gold! Gold!
Erstes Signal, erste Münze, ein
Hauptfund, eine Goldmünze ...
Alles nur ein Spiel für Erwachsene?
Für die Archäologin Marion Brüggler nicht.
Bei den Meisterschaften will sie mit den
Sondengängern ins Gespräch kommen
und darüber aufklären, welche Zerstörung
von den Schatzsuchern ausgehen kann.
So meine, ja, schlimmste Erfahrung:
Da hatten wir ein Gräberfeld untersucht,
und da ist dann nachts jemand mit
einem Dreizack durchgegangen
und hat alles rausgewühlt,
was zu bekommen war.
Man konnte die Spuren von dem
Dreizack noch sehen.
Und da geht natürlich dann einiges kaputt.
Verbündeter im Kampf gegen
derartige Raubgräber
ist ihr Kollege Peter Henrich aus Koblenz.
Auch er hat mit immer mehr
Sondengängern zu tun.
Er erklärt, was sie brauchen,
um eine Genehmigung zu bekommen,
und was zu tun ist,
wenn sie etwas finden.
Ja, ich pack’ mal hier wieder ein.
Die sind alle durchnummeriert.
Genau, so soll das sein:
Fundzettel, Fund in ’ner Fundtüte
und nummeriert, wunderbar!
Das sind also alles römische Münzen,
1. Jahrhundert nach Christus vermutlich.
Bei vielen landet so was
einfach in der Schrottkiste.
Hier wird’s … kriegt’s ’ne Nummer,
wird eingemessen und wird im
Fundbericht aufgenommen.
Perfekt. So soll’s sein!
Viele Sondengänger kooperieren
gern mit den Archäologen,
andere fühlen sich von ihnen
unnötig kontrolliert.
Sie wollen Abenteuer –
so wie Axel Thiel von Kracht.
Er betreibt ein Internetportal
mit dem Namen
„Deutsche Sondengänger Union,
eine Schutzgemeinschaft“.
Weil von Archäologie-Seite
oft behauptet wird,
dass man eben generell ’ne
Genehmigung braucht
und dass Leute, die eben diese
Genehmigung nicht haben,
als Raubgräber unterwegs sind.
Und das ist einfach falsch.
Solche pauschalen Aussagen,
wie öfters …
wie ich es öfters hier im Umfeld
schon gehört habe …
Man darf eigentlich überall sondeln,
ohne Restriktionen zu fürchten.
Das ist definitiv falsch.
Die Fronten sind verhärtet.
Denn es gibt die schwarzen Schafe:
Einige Sondengänger jagen
zum Beispiel gezielt nach
Militaria, Waffen, Bomben oder Munition
wie hier im Reichswald.
Das ist nicht nur gefährlich,
sondern auch verboten –
genauso wie die nicht genehmigte
Suche auf Grabungsstätten.
Das sind ganz gezielte Raubgräber
mit mafiösen Strukturen,
die ganz gezielt solche
Grabhügel anfahren
und dort ganz gezielt
Raubgrabungen machen,
um halt kommerziell das
Ganze zu betreiben.
Für die Archäologen ist
das eine Katastrophe.
Und wenn es aus so ’nem Befund,
aus so ’nem Grab,
wo Knochenschnitzereien drin waren
und ein Totenbett lag,
wenn da die ganzen kompletten
Gefäße und Münzen weg sind,
ja, weil sie jemand vorher geklaut hat …
Das ist dann für uns ein Riesenverlust!
Die Archäologen wollen die Sondengänger
weiter zur Zusammenarbeit bekehren
und Amateure zu Partnern machen,
ihnen zeigen, wie wertvoll die Schätze
im Boden für die Nachwelt sind.